die einzige sache ist halt wirklich er
hat zu mir gemeint ich dürfte auf gar
keinen fall an seinem pc gehen
ich muss halt etwas aufnehmen leute also
leute folgendermaßen ich hab mich rein
geschlichen bei luca ich bin bei luca
eingebrochen
wir sind jetzt hier in seinen aufnahmen
das hier ist es auch wenn man jetzt
versuchen erst gerade einkaufen hier
schnell eine folge minecraft aufzunehmen
er hat mir natürlich verboten und seinen
pc zu gehen und verboten mit seinem
account zu spielen ich möchte einfach
mit dem concorde account jumping spielen
die leute so ein bisschen trollen und
gucken wie sie reagieren wenn konkret
aber mehr als einen sprung schafft und
vor allem schauen ob sie an alle
wirklich so sehr hassen wie man sagt ja
leute hier
da unten ist der pc leute wir versuchen
jetzt einfach nur unser glück und hoffen
dass er uns jetzt nicht erwischt werden
wir hier sind genau okay leute wir sind
jetzt hier im aufnahme zimmer in den
heiligen hallen hier sehen wir den
ganzen lose darf das lud merchandise
münchen und häberli
ihr wisst ihr was ich werde bald nicht
an schnipsen ich wollte ihm nicht wehtun
weil er nichts dafür kann dass ihr über
luca steht als ich das nicht ausgesucht
er wohl von mutter gekauft
das ist ein armer kleiner stoffhund der
nichts dafür kann dass er hier ist
genauso kolonie und vitello die können
einfach nichts dafür
deswegen beschäftige ich mich jetzt nur
mit dem stoff daher aus warum ist denn
dann startet direkt ins spiel
wir sind auf play that i ich habe
gestorben also um gelegt dass ich für
mich halbwegs passt und wir sind hier
von crafter seht ihr da im tab wir
probiert einfach mal hier so mit diesem
wunderschönen texture pack eine rolle
jump league zu spielen
leute die runde fühlt sich so langsam da
kann man gleich loslegen
ich bin sehr gespannt wie ich damit
spielen weil er mit dem ganzen ludwig
bremse hier müsse so gesagt
hier nehme auch nicht so ich auch in
dieser okay wie heißt eigentlich so
kraft was ihr treiben genau wisst ihr
was kann man sich in der runde nicken
ausprobieren und zwar auto nie king aus
und will muss dass der service ist aber
unser server alles klar
ich hab gerade versucht aus dem server
rauszugehen dann das auto nicht zu
disable dass die leute sehen dass ich
keine kraft da bin
das hat nicht funktioniert die 100
einfach mal startet ok gehen die nächste
so leute die runde startet die erste
runde jump nicht als konkreter
ich freue mich freue mich immer vor wie
gewinnen das ding am ende eine schöne
player congo after race around junge
okay ja es ist natürlich auch ein luca
fmv dann will ich jetzt aber nichts
ändert und merkel sie dran war wenn wir
hier schon options
vw enormen auf ein normalniveau wie
natürlich die volltext apec alter dass
gott wie das spielt sich mega komisch
alles klar
okay okay soweit kann ich es aber
schaffen hier ja wohl aller wesen sap
ist sehr viel schwerer ist es alles so
ungewohnt hier und ich weiß auch nicht
genau wie lange luca weg bleiben wird
ist natürlich nicht gesagt dass die
blöcke sind viel länger als man denkt
der junge über diese hunde niemals
gewinnen niemals
jawohl der allerbesten wir haben eine
mannschaft mit lukas tat ab das ist dass
das schild alter das wird nach unten hin
bekommen kozak modul zweiter stets haben
es geschafft
all das ist ungewohnt man dieses niveau
wie alter schwede die kann man so
spielen wir könnten tatsächlich bald im
modul 2 abschließen okay wäre auch das
hier geschafft diesen sprung geschafft
mir noch es sieht gut aus ist sie gut
aus heute
es sieht sehr gut aus check point 2
erreicht alte es läuft es aber die sache
ist auch ich hab ja sonst hier nichts
mit dem jahr aufnehmen könnte ich muss
mit seinen sachen aufnehmen ich aber
keine maus hier dabei und ja ok alter
alter alter es geht noch an könnt ihr
junge die einzige sache ist halt
wirklich er zu mir gemeint ich dürfte
auf gar keinen fall an einen pc gehen
ich muss halt mal auf dem leute also
lukas einer der als einem nicht erlaubt
irgendwie die eigenen sachen zu benutzen
als strikt gesagt du darfst nicht an
meinem pc und ganz ehrlich ich habe auch
gesagt ich muss aufnehmen so nie zuvor
machen können
ok alles klar selbst schuld denke ich
jetzt nicht
also es ist mir egal solange mich nicht
erwischt das haben wir so sechseinhalb
stunden später jetzt müssen wir aber
hier drauf glaube ich sieht megabyte
auskomme jobs schaffen
ja man kann sich auch ganz geschafft
leute es läuft es läuft es läuft jetzt
kann es nicht mehr aufhalten
nein wir sind auf diese machten blog
hier einfach gelandet junge ist du
kannst es schaffen als würdest du dich
selbst erzeugen ja wohl und nice den
jackpot aber auch mit genug junge welt
wir sind bereit beim modul 7
wir sind einfach eiskalt beim modul 7
jawohl und das ein pfeiler und das
einstein schwert jesse und leute leute
wir steuern auf den ersten platz zu wir
steuern tatsächlich auf den fucking
ersten platz das gibt's nicht
das gibt sich alter mit diesem mit
dieser equipment mit diesem gstaad
voraussetzung
okay okay leute es läuft alles so weit
die runde dauert auch save nicht mehr
lange dessen maximal noch zwei drei vier
minuten da haben wir einfach alles geld
geschafft aufzunehmen ohne dass er kommt
ich spiele bisschen jump league ist okay
ich hab' ich habe die ganze zeit gesagt
ich muss doch musste aus aufnehmen es
gibt diese holz zwei regeln
aber ich muss auch videos muss ich jetzt
sage euch es erstens keine fuchs ins
schlafzimmer und zweitens nicht
aufnehmen an meinem pc vor allem nicht
gebissen mit einem account aber drin
oder nee ich dachte
wir sind nicht nur dann zeigt das noch
nicht so wild
die töten mich durch richtig da wie es
mich nicht weiterspielen
komm schon ich will aber weiter okay du
gehst einfach runter berücksichtigt
dank david alaba team wie sie einfach
thieme ich hole ich dich holen der
turnaround ist der concord der trend ist
patentiert denke dass eine chance denkst
du ist wirkliche chance hier zack ein
hit also ich kann ja nicht okay ich hab
auch noch ein wir haben ein leben lautet
nein da ist jemand da ist jemand da ist
jemand der vorne ist noch einer ist
immer noch fucked up von e.on e.on
kämpft gegen anna sehr gut kämpfen
anders ist gut das finde ich gut
auf jeden fall ich versuche jedoch die
facebook zu fixen hier unten bin ich
leute hey alter schwede
okay ist der kompass wir können das
könnte was werden alter was jo-jo
aber was leute selbst der beste
ersehnten junior kam mit dieser technik
was ist das einfach nicht gewinnen
aber ich hoffe dass ich das video
trotzdem halbwegs anschauen wir haben
kiel gemacht mein ziel war einfach
eigentlich viel zu machen
ich wollte zwar auch gewinnen abermals
über eigentlichen kiel zu machen und
haben klar gemacht dass war es so weit
von mir wenn ihr luca heißt treibt in
die kommentare
wenn ihr findet dass luca gut mit der
situation umgegangen ich schreibe es in
die kommentare
wir sehen uns beim nächsten video wieder
biss dann macht sie gut und